Hi guys, it's Michael Shea, your first day V.
大家好，我是 Michael Shea，您第一天 V。
I wanted to do a shout out and tell you how excited I am for season three.
我想大声告诉你们我对第三季有多兴奋。
And I also wanted to tell you what an amazing time I had all nine seasons on how I met your mother.
我还想告诉你，关于我如何认识你母亲的九季，我度过了一段多么美好的时光。
I mean we had such a blast.
我的意思是我们玩得很开心。
I mean we were surrounded by such incredible writers and actors and of course Pan and Suzy and this amazing production team.
我的意思是，我们周围都是如此令人难以置信的作家和演员，当然还有潘和苏西以及这个令人惊叹的制作团队。
We spent a lot of time together and every morning I would say we got a lot of work to do I miss it so much.
我们花了很多时间在一起，每天早上我都会说我们有很多工作要做，我非常想念它。
I miss my himian family.
我想念我的希米安家人。
It was such a great time in my life Can we do it all again?
这是我生命中如此美好的时光，我们可以重来一次吗？
I'd love to have a wonderful season three I could go on and on and on but I'll leave you with this guys guys guys Let us see.
我很想有一个精彩的第三季，我可以继续下去，但我会把你们留给这些家伙，让我们看看。
Please permit me to tell you everything.
请允许我告诉你一切。
We York City.
我们约克城。
Guys guys guys welcome to how we made your mother.
伙计们，欢迎来到我们如何造就你们的母亲。
I'm Josh Radroom here with my friend Craig Thomas Josh guys guys guys.
我是乔什·拉德鲁姆，我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯·乔什一起在这里。
It's like a catchphrase.
这就像一句口号。
It was it was an onset catchphrase and we just got it.
这是一个流行语，我们刚刚明白了。
It was We're that was Michael Shea our first AD from Not not the pilot.
迈克尔·谢伊 (Michael Shea) 是《我们是》的《Not not》试播集的第一个广告。
He didn't do the pilot.
他没有做飞行员。
He does only what he do all the way to the end he was Pam Frimey, he was Barra Syed the entire time.
他只做他一直做的事，直到最后他都是帕姆·弗里米，他一直都是巴拉·赛义德。
And directed.
并执导。
Directed, yeah.
导演，是的。
Great guy.
很棒的家伙。
He was great to hear from you, Michael.
他很高兴收到你的来信，迈克尔。
We'll have you on the show.
我们会让你参加演出。
Thanks for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
We don't have Michael Shea here, but we do have an extra special, wonderful guest in the form of...
我们这里没有迈克尔·谢伊，但我们确实有一位特别的、出色的客人，他是……
Craig, introduce our special guest.
克雷格，介绍一下我们的特邀嘉宾。
We have a Hymm All Star writer.
我们有一位赞美诗全明星作家。
This is his first episode, right?
这是他的第一集吧？
This is joined in season three and stayed a long time.
这是在第三季加入的，并且持续了很长时间。
We'll talk about the rest of the run of having this wonderful man, hilarious dude, has done so many cool things since How Much Mother 2, the great Joe Kelly, ladies and gentlemen.
我们将谈论这个出色的男人，搞笑的家伙，自从《多少妈妈2》以来做了很多很酷的事情，伟大的乔·凯利，女士们先生们，我们将讨论剩下的事情。
Joe Kelly.
乔·凯利.
JK.
JK。
How are you guys?
你们好吗？
Good to be.
很好。
So such a pleasure.
太高兴了。
Thanks for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
Yeah, pleasure.
是的，很高兴。
Yeah.
是的。
Joe, so I'm trying to remember we, I think we had read your spec scripts like a couple, like the year before we hired you.
乔，所以我试图记住我们，我想我们已经像情侣一样阅读了您的规范脚本，就像我们雇用您的前一年一样。
I remember reading you and really liking your stuff.
我记得读过你的文章并且非常喜欢你的东西。
And like the stars didn't align.
就像星星没有对齐一样。
And then we got even season three.
然后我们甚至得到了第三季。
What were you doing right before you joined how much mother in season three?
在加入第三季《多少妈妈》之前，你在做什么？
Was it SNL?
是周六夜现场吗？
I was trying to piece it together.
我试图把它拼凑起来。
Give us like a portrait of where you were like leading up to that.
请给我们描述一下您在这之前的情况。
I love the SNL and then I came to L.A.
我喜欢 SNL，然后我来到了洛杉矶。
And I made, I was, Joel Gallon was paying my rent.
我做到了，我是，乔尔·加隆正在支付我的房租。
I was doing MTV movie awards.
我当时正在做 MTV 电影颁奖典礼。
I had been directed the first movie.
我导演了第一部电影。
I was in another teen movie.
我在另一部青少年电影中。
I mean, we really loved that movie.
我的意思是，我们真的很喜欢那部电影。
I'm a huge, now the King movie guy.
我现在是一个巨大的国王电影人。
I remember that, I remember that.
我记得那个，我记得那个。
And like William Shatner, the roast of William Shatner, like I was just doing that.
就像威廉·沙特纳一样，威廉·沙特纳的烤肉，就像我刚刚这样做的那样。
And I remember meeting you guys and feeling great about it.
我记得见到你们并且感觉很棒。
And then no, he didn't hire me, it's a season two.
然后不，他没有雇用我，这是第二季。
That's what I remember too.
我也记得这样的事。
I remember we really liked you, but we didn't hire you.
我记得我们真的很喜欢你，但我们没有雇用你。
You probably hit all your guts.
你可能已经耗尽了所有的胆量。
It worked out season three.
第三季已经成功了。
But I came, we came around.
但我来了，我们都过来了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Joe was, how I made your mother, your first staffing on a like an episodic show?
乔，我是如何让你的母亲成为你的第一个像情景剧一样的工作人员的？
was and I was terrified.
是的，我很害怕。
I was the new guy.
我是新人。
Everyone had been together for two seasons.
每个人都在一起度过了两个赛季。
They all talked about this epic lightsaber fight they had in the parking lot one day.
他们都谈论了有一天在停车场进行的这场史诗般的光剑战斗。
I would never catch up to the glorious time they had that day.
我永远赶不上他们那天的辉煌时光。
So slow and steady and every time I said something, Stephen Lloyd would wince and pinch his nose.
如此缓慢而稳定，每次我说话时，斯蒂芬·劳埃德都会皱起眉头，捏住鼻子。
So my goal was just just to say something and not have Stephen Lloyd wince pinch his nose and put his head down.
所以我的目标只是说点什么，而不是让史蒂芬·劳埃德皱起眉头捏住鼻子，低下头。
And I think I got there towards the end.
我想我已经接近尾声了。
Oh, you got there.
哦，你到了。
You got there.
你到了那里。
So you came from like a heavy like joke sketch background.
所以你来自一个像笑话素描一样沉重的背景。
Did you feel like comedically like you could hang and you had to learn more about story structure and character stuff?
你是否觉得很滑稽，好像你可以被绞死，你必须了解更多关于故事结构和角色的东西？
Like where did you feel like you were your strengths and weaknesses were when you first joined?
就像你刚加入时觉得自己的优势和劣势在哪里？
Yes, I mean sketch in improv.
是的，我的意思是即兴素描。
And I was confident in those arenas.
我对这些领域充满信心。
And then I was good at pitching bids and how much mother with the pops was a great place for me to be, it melded the two very sketchy at times with the things we did.
然后我很擅长投标，妈妈和流行音乐对我来说是一个很棒的地方，它有时将两者非常粗略地与我们所做的事情融合在一起。
It could be sketchy show, yeah.
是的，这可能是一个粗略的表演。
Yeah, in all sorts of ways, especially for the others.
是的，在各个方面，尤其是对其他人而言。
It's sketchy in every sense of the world.
从世界的各个角度来看，它都是粗略的。
The bracket is fairly sketchy.
支架相当粗略。
Yeah, but in five years I really learned the other half of the power of the show.
是的，但五年后我真正了解了这部剧的另一半力量。
And I learned again and again, I would always get really excited about the bigger comedic ideas and the emotional ones were always what registered more to the audience and were better and the stuff that grounded.
我一次又一次地了解到，我总是对更大的喜剧想法感到非常兴奋，而情感上的想法总是更能吸引观众，更好，更接地气。
Every time I think I learned that lesson, I write a first draft of something and it's just all jokes that are 12 out of 10 on the meter and I just have to dial it down and dial it down.
每当我认为我吸取了这一教训时，我都会写一些东西的初稿，而这只是所有笑话，满分10分中的12分，我只需要不断地降低它。
But yeah, it was, it was.
但是，是的，确实如此，确实如此。
Well, you went on to co-create a show that is like really heart forward, right?
好吧，你们继续共同创作了一部真正令人心潮澎湃的节目，对吧？
Like, do you feel...
比如，你有没有感觉...
Joe created Ted Lasso, which is, I guess, the only works with Ted Protagonist, which I appreciate.
乔创作了《泰德套索》，我想这是唯一一部以泰德为主角的作品，我很欣赏。
Yeah, so many times.
是啊，很多次了。
You worked for the most famous Ted's in some kind of history.
你曾为历史上最著名的特德工作过。
But did you feel like by the time you...
但当你的时候你有没有感觉...
Sorry.
对不起。
But did you feel like by the time you left, talking about your mother, that you really had learned how to write in that way, or that you picked up that skill?
但是，当你离开时，谈论你的母亲时，你是否感觉你真的学会了如何以这种方式写作，或者你学会了这种技能？
Yeah, I mean, again, it took a while to understand, because the Ted Lasso started off with the commercials that were just a football coach in England, and when Jason said he wanted to do the show, I was like, that's gonna be a show, okay?
是的，我的意思是，我又花了一段时间才明白，因为特德·拉索一开始的广告只是英格兰的一名足球教练，当杰森说他想做这个节目时，我想，这将是一个节目，好吗？
I can keep pitching those England bits.
我可以继续投出那些英格兰的片段。
And then I had no idea, it wasn't until editing, I understood because it was going to be a funnier show.
然后我不知道，直到编辑，我才明白，因为这将是一个更有趣的节目。
No, it's going to be a longer, more emotional show.
不，这将是一场更长、更感人的演出。
There was a push and pull up until the final edits of season one.
在第一季的最终剪辑之前，我们一直在推拉。
And then it was like, oh, okay, that's the tone we're landing on.
然后就好像，哦，好吧，这就是我们的基调。
And it was much, again, much more sincere than I imagined going in.
而且这比我想象的要真诚得多。
Again, just pitching my fart and poop jokes and seeing what sticks to the wall.
再说一遍，只是讲我的放屁和便便笑话，看看墙上粘着什么。
But you are very capable of those other speeds.
但你非常有能力达到其他速度。
And I will say like, we needed your energy.
我会说，我们需要你的能量。
needed you to come in with that energy because I think we were afraid that we were such an emo sitcom, right?
需要你带着这种能量进来，因为我想我们担心我们是一部如此情绪化的情景喜剧，对吧？
And we knew we were on CBS.
我们知道我们在哥伦比亚广播公司。
Like the biggest hit show was two and a half men on CBS and Aaron after How Much Mother and would have millions more viewers than us every Monday night.
就像哥伦比亚广播公司最热门的节目《两个半男人》和《多少妈妈》之后的《亚伦》一样，每个星期一晚上的观众数量都会比我们多数百万。
And we were really lived in like this inferiority to that.
我们确实生活在这样的自卑之中。
And we were always getting the note from CBS and like Les Moonves was like the president of CBS like super like macho old school dude.
我们总是收到哥伦比亚广播公司的通知，就像莱斯·穆恩维斯（Les Moonves）就像哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的总裁一样，超级有男子气概的老派家伙。
Everyone kept saying like if you want to stay on the air maybe a a few more jokes for the dudes.
每个人都不停地说，如果你想继续直播，可以给伙计们再讲几个笑话。
And that just takes the stuff to talk about the bracket, the March Madness-based episode, where Barney is in full sociopathic dudes mode.
这只是谈论括号中的内容，以疯狂三月为基础的剧集，其中巴尼处于完全反社会的家伙模式。
But like, we wanted that energy.
但就像，我们想要那种能量。
You are very funny, Joe.
你很有趣，乔。
You were very, like, you came in very hot with jokes, with funny jokes.
你非常非常热情地讲笑话，讲有趣的笑话。
You were on SNL, you had done Sketch, you had performed, you had performed improv, like you lived in Amsterdam, and like, you were on stage.
你在《周六夜现场》上，你拍过《素描》，你表演过，你表演过即兴表演，就像你住在阿姆斯特丹一样，就像你在舞台上一样。
Like, we needed some of that energy.
就像，我们需要一些能量。
because we, if left door on devices, Carter and I are very emo.
因为我们，如果在设备上留下门，卡特和我都非常情绪化。
You know, we are, we are, we are, we are writing like a humor list, essentially humor list.
你知道，我们是，我们是，我们是，我们正在写一个幽默列表，本质上是幽默列表。
I, we, look, I think we, Carter and I would always say like, we never worry too much about the jokes.
我，我们，听着，我想我们，卡特和我总是会说，我们从不太担心笑话。
We always want an interesting structure to know what it's emotionally about and then come in and someone like machine gun us some jokes and we, you were, you brought that energy, Joe.
我们总是想要一个有趣的结构来知道它在情感上是什么，然后进来，像机关枪一样的人给我们讲一些笑话，我们，你，你带来了能量，乔。
And then I think over the seasons that you were there, We are Emonus rubbed off on you a little bit.
然后我想，在你在那里的几个赛季里，《我们是埃莫努斯》对你产生了一点影响。
And I think you also steered us more towards like, hey, remember, there's some men that watch how I met your mother too.
我想你也引导我们更多地走向，嘿，记住，也有一些男人在看我是如何遇见你母亲的。
And they might like things like sports.
他们可能喜欢运动之类的东西。
And so it was, I don't know, I think it was a good match.
事情就是这样，我不知道，我认为这是一场很好的比赛。
I think we were a good match for one another, I feel.
我觉得我们很般配。
Yeah, I know it was the same for me.
是的，我知道这对我来说也是一样的。
I also was like, Jason would always say, let's break the story of a drama.
我也想，杰森总是说，让我们打破戏剧的故事。
And then the jokes will just add afterwards.
然后笑话就会在之后添加。
So as much as the story works on an emotional level.
因此，尽管这个故事在情感层面上起作用。
And then when we broke those stories, I always remember the detail on the whiteboards of each beat was always tiny writing and it really filled up every scene with what the drive was, what was going on, and that's for five characters.
然后，当我们打破这些故事时，我总是记得每个节拍的白板上的细节总是很小的文字，它确实充满了每个场景，其中包括驱动器是什么，发生了什么，这是五个角色的。
And we really focused on that way more than what was gonna be funny, or like a set PC Act break here or there would be on the board, but it really was we would break a little romantic comedy every week.
我们真的更关注这种方式，而不是有趣的东西，或者像板上的设定 PC Act 打破这里或那里，但实际上我们每周都会打破一点浪漫喜剧。
Well, it feels like you can always insert jokes into a solid structure that's emotionally compelling, but the reverse is like to jam heart into a joke filter, which is pretty difficult.
嗯，感觉你总是可以将笑话插入到情感上引人注目的坚实结构中，但反过来就像将心塞进笑话过滤器中一样，这是相当困难的。
We really wouldn't worry about whether it was that funny when we were breaking the story.
当我们报道这个故事时，我们真的不会担心它是否那么有趣。
I don't know if that's probably really strange and maybe it was alarming to you to come into that, but it was like, we were pretty serious, it's true.
我不知道这是否真的很奇怪，也许你对此感到震惊，但我们是很认真的，这是真的。
We would have like these very elaborate lengthy outlines that were just the emotional beats of the scenes and then add jokes.
我们希望这些非常详尽的冗长的轮廓只是场景的情感节拍，然后添加笑话。
And you were very, very good at that, Joe.
乔，你在这方面非常非常擅长。
So we were lucky to have you join there.
所以我们很幸运你能加入那里。
And this episode could not have been a better example of just let's just go insane with some Barney jokes.
这一集再好不过的例子了，让我们一起为巴尼的笑话疯狂吧。
And this is really an all-timer in that category.
这确实是该类别中的历史记录。
It's bonkers.
太疯狂了。
It is fun.
这很有趣。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you to you in New York City will be right back.
我写了这首小曲给你唱给你听，纽约市很快就会回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
It also feels, Craig, we've talked about like when you really centered Ted as the romantic hero, it's like you need like a palate cleanser a little bit.
克雷格，我们也谈到过，当你真正把泰德作为浪漫英雄的中心时，你就需要一点味觉清洁剂。
Not because it's like we're sick of Ted.
不是因为我们厌倦了特德。
It's more like that's one speed that we can do, but there's also like we we have these other, we have these other speeds that are like really funny and strange.
这更像是我们可以做到的一种速度，但我们也有其他的速度，我们有这些其他的速度，这些速度真的很有趣和奇怪。
I mean, we can talk about like how Barney is like, this is one of his, it's like a really funny episode for Barney, but it's also like, he said some stuff that's just like, oh my God, dude, you're sort of a war criminal in this episode.
我的意思是，我们可以谈论巴尼的样子，这是他的一个，这对巴尼来说就像是一个非常有趣的插曲，但也就像，他说了一些类似的话，天哪，伙计，你在这一集中有点像战犯。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But it's, there's a lot of really funny stuff, but it's this is, yeah, we went big.
但这是，有很多非常有趣的事情，但是，是的，我们做得很大。
This was us going 12 out of 10.
这是我们 10 人中的 12 人。
And we definitely went 12 out of 10.
10 人中我们肯定选了 12 人。
He's the scorpion who stings in this episode.
他就是这一集中蜇人的蝎子。
Like he is honoring his nature.
就像他尊重他的本性一样。
Although I will ask you something and I'm getting into the weeds of this episode and we don't have to go super specific just yet.
虽然我会问你一些事情，而且我正在深入了解这一集，但我们还不必说得太具体。
But I remember there was kind of a thing that Craig and I talked about as we watched the first two seasons, Joe, where we're like, does Barney sleep with a lot of women?
但我记得克雷格和我在观看前两季时讨论过一件事，乔，我们的想法是，巴尼和很多女人睡过吗？
Or does Barney talk about sleeping with a lot of women?
或者巴尼谈论过和很多女人上床吗？
And there was kind of question of like, is he an actual Lothario or is he a great storyteller?
有人问，他是一个真正的洛塔里奥，还是一个伟大的讲故事的人？
And in this episode, it's kind of like, he's an actual Lothario.
在这一集中，他就像是一个真正的洛塔里奥。
He's actually like having sex with all these women, he's documenting it in a scrapbook.
他实际上喜欢与所有这些女人发生性关系，他将其记录在剪贴簿中。
You know, it's sociopathic, edging into psychopathic, but he, it feels like these women really, he really did, he was with all these women.
你知道，这是反社会的，接近精神病态的，但他，感觉这些女人真的，他真的这么做了，他和所有这些女人在一起。
So I wondered if you guys ever, if that was ever absurd.
所以我想知道你们是否曾经这样做过，这是否荒谬。
I didn't prefer it when you realize he does not have a very high success rate and he's making a lot of it up.
当你意识到他的成功率不是很高而且他在编造很多东西时，我不喜欢这样。
And even in this one, he could still be making a lot of it up.
即使在这一点上，他仍然可能会编造很多东西。
If this one has a flots that were too committing to the idea that he's really getting all of these women, but we were so enamored over the idea of the bracket.
如果这个人有一群过于执着于他真的得到所有这些女人的想法，但我们非常迷恋支架的想法。
This was, again, this was another one where it was like, hey guys, if you do a bracket, if you do like a March Madness themed episode, we'll promote you a lot in March Madness.
这又是另一件事，嘿伙计们，如果你做了一个支架，如果你确实喜欢疯狂三月主题剧集，我们会在疯狂三月中大力宣传你。
And this was like, you joined at a weird time, Joe, because the writer's guild strike, you were probably just getting used to having this job on how Mitch Mother and the writer's guild strike hit.
这就像，乔，你在一个奇怪的时间加入，因为作家行会罢工，你可能只是习惯了米奇母亲和作家行会罢工的影响。
And then three months of, everyone was freaked out.
三个月过去了，所有人都惊慌失措。
We were like, is this, are we gonna get canceled?
我们当时想，这样的话，我们会被取消吗？
Is this the show gonna come out of this?
这部剧会由此展开吗？
They have three months to realize they don't need me.
他们有三个月的时间意识到他们不需要我。
get rid of me.
摆脱我吧。
I don't know if you remember you we threw this my episode was coming up and I was like hey everyone we're going on strike on Friday and I was like and you guys threw together a story and and sent me off to write it and told me to get it in and just write something down get it in I don't want to get in trouble with the WGA but you got me basically you got me paid right before the strike started you got me my script fee which I always thought was the coolest solid thing.
我不知道你是否还记得你是否记得我们把这个我的剧集即将推出，我就像嘿大家，我们周五要罢工，我就像你们拼凑了一个故事，然后让我去写它，并告诉我把它写下来，写下一些东西，把它写下来，我不想惹上WGA的麻烦，但你基本上在罢工开始之前就给了我报酬，你给了我剧本费，我一直认为这是最酷的固体东西。
But then we, and that was like, I really, I charged it out.
但后来我们就好像，我真的，我把它充电了。
I was really proud of it.
我真的很自豪。
And then like three months later, we come back from the strike and you're like, yeah, yeah, we're starting over.
然后大约三个月后，我们从罢工中回来，你会说，是的，是的，我们要重新开始。
That was the favorite of you.
那是你最喜欢的。
We are starting with the blank page.
我们从空白页开始。
And I was like, okay, thank you, thank you.
我当时想，好吧，谢谢你，谢谢你。
That's awesome.
太棒了。
Joe, what did you, when you, when I mean, you went on to obviously you're running shows now, but like, what did you learn from how I met your mother from that writer's room?
乔，当你，当我的意思是，你继续显然你现在正在主持节目时，你做了什么，但是，你从我在那个作家的房间遇见你母亲的过程中学到了什么？
What did you learn from Carter and Craig?
你从卡特和克雷格身上学到了什么？
What were the things like the gems you took from your time on the show?
您在演出期间获得了哪些宝贵的东西？
I would always do.
我总是会这样做。
On Detroiters, we just did it the same way because that's the only way I knew.
在底特律，我们只是以同样的方式做，因为这是我知道的唯一方法。
I just loved the breaking of story, the way we broke the story, and the doing it table.
我只是喜欢故事的分解，我们分解故事的方式，以及做事的桌子。
Just the structure of how much a mother.
只是结构多少是一个母亲。
And I'd always have little Carter's and Craig's over my ear of Carter's shoulder was you love this you love this idea on Monday love it on Friday don't don't lose faith in it and Craig on the other shoulder is is this line as good as it can be is this line as good as it could be can we beat this can we beat this and to not fall in love with things and like it really was like I've always every single moment of every page has always had those kind of two people that we were that you've thought of us that way because Detroiters is a fucking great show.
我总是把小卡特和克雷格挂在我的耳朵上，卡特的肩膀是你喜欢这个，你喜欢周一的这个想法，周五喜欢它，不要对它失去信心，另一只肩膀上的克雷格，这条线尽可能好，这条线尽可能好，我们能打败这个，我们能打败这个，不要爱上事物，就像我总是在每一页的每一个时刻都有这样的两个人，我们你是不是这么想我们的，因为《底特律》真是一场精彩的演出。
All of you've been such cool stuff since I'm very proud that we're even like little angel and devil or angel and angel or whatever the fuck we were.
你们所有人都太酷了，因为我很自豪我们甚至像小天使和魔鬼，或者天使和天使，或者不管我们是什么。
But it's interesting how Carter who was the model for Ted was the one who was like don't lose faith.
但有趣的是，作为特德的模特的卡特却是那个不要失去信心的人。
Yeah.
是的。
He was a good one.
他是个好人。
Yeah.
是的。
And not, not, not necessarily Carter and Craig, with all of the, all of the things you all taught me, but when I think about how much mother, because I was, as you said, I was in that gear of like, all right, you guys are doing all this brainy stuff, romantic stuff.
不是，不是，不一定是卡特和克雷格，以及你们教给我的所有、所有的事情，但是当我想到有多少母亲，因为我，正如你所说，我处于那种状态，好吧，你们正在做所有这些聪明的事情，浪漫的事情。
I'm just kind of leaning back in my chair and pitching bits when you ask me to pitch bits.
当你要求我投稿时，我只是靠在椅子上投稿。
And that was me learning from Chuck Tatham and Dave Hemmingson, who had, Dave was so busy on his own stuff.
这就是我向查克·塔瑟姆（Chuck Tatham）和戴夫·海明森（Dave Hemmingson）学习的，戴夫非常忙于自己的事情。
He couldn't wait for five o'clock to go write two movies and go home and watch three more and play tennis.
他迫不及待地等到五点钟就去写两部电影，然后回家再看三部电影，然后打网球。
You know, he just had an amazing, her Miami grandeur like time turner thing.
你知道，他刚刚经历了一件令人惊奇的事情，她的迈阿密宏伟就像时间转换器一样。
Is he coming the next day?
他第二天会来吗？
And it would be the math wouldn't add up of what he had done from when he left every single morning, every single morning.
从他离开时起的每一天、每一个早晨，数学都无法将他所做的事情加起来。
And then check Tatum was the opposite of like five o'clock man, I'm gonna grab a martini and set my my hot tub with the cigar.
然后检查塔图姆是否与五点钟的人相反，我要喝一杯马提尼，然后在我的热水浴缸里放上雪茄。
Good.
好的。
Adios.
再见。
But I will not think about this until I'm back in this room.
但在我回到这个房间之前我不会考虑这个。
Yes.
是的。
But both guys were, hey guys, we need to, we need to pitch on a hat for Ted and like half the room.
但两个人都是，嘿伙计们，我们需要，我们需要为特德和一半房间的人戴上帽子。
I go, well, you should wear a hat.
我走了，好吧，你应该戴帽子。
You should wear a scarf.
你应该戴一条围巾。
You shouldn't wear a scarf, it should be this.
你不应该戴围巾，应该是这个。
And Dave and Chuck are always just, you know, hot, top hat.
戴夫和查克总是，你知道，很性感。
I'll give you what you have, I will, I will do the assignment.
我会给你你所拥有的，我会的，我会完成任务。
You're right.
你说得对。
Pitch until until we, I get you to laugh or we get a green light and I'm not going to question in the direction.
一直投球，直到我们让你笑或者我们得到绿灯，我不会询问方向。
And I would say going from how much mother to shows where I'm in charge of the like, oh, we're going this way.
我想说的是，从“多少母亲”到“我负责哪里”之类的，哦，我们就这样走。
We're going that way.
我们正朝那个方向走。
I much prefer going back in my chairs going here.
我更喜欢回到我的椅子上去这里。
Ten ideas.
十个想法。
Take what you want.
拿你想要的。
And I miss that.
我很怀念这一点。
It's such a different job, right?
这是一份非常不同的工作，对吧？
I remember emailing.
我记得发过电子邮件。
I email Carter Craig like a couple I'm like, I just want to say, I'm so sorry for how it behaves.
我像一对情侣一样给卡特·克雷格发电子邮件，我只想说，我对它的行为感到非常抱歉。
I'm so grateful for you.
我非常感谢你。
I understand.
我明白。
It's like apologizing to your parents when you finally have kids.
这就像当你终于有了孩子时向你的父母道歉。
Yeah.
是的。
I didn't understand what you guys were up to.
我不明白你们在搞什么鬼。
And I just wanted Chuck Tatham's and Dave Hemingsons to be pitching me stuff and that be questioning things and then bumping on stuff.
我只是希望查克·泰森（Chuck Tatham）和戴夫·海明森（Dave Hemingsons）向我推销一些东西，质疑一些东西，然后碰撞一些东西。
Funny.
有趣的。
But yeah, you carmically had to become a showrunner.
但是，是的，你必须成为一名制片人。
It was your come-up.
这是你的出现。
It was a very successful TV showrunner.
这是一个非常成功的电视节目主持人。
but come up, you were great, like you were the guy, you were doing those things.
但说起来，你很棒，就像你就是那个人，你在做那些事情。
Dave having sent Chuck to eat them too great, how much mother writers it really were, like what Joe said, just give you jokes, they gave you jokes.
戴夫让查克把它们吃得太厉害了，这真是多少母亲作家，就像乔说的，只要给你讲笑话，他们就给你讲笑话。
You were that guy, you were that guy.
你就是那个人，你就是那个人。
You owned that role, I'm glad that they were like role models to you, but you became that guy as time went on and it's cool that you got to do the other job of being a showrunner, but you also need the Joe Kelly.
你拥有这个角色，我很高兴他们对你来说就像榜样，但随着时间的推移，你变成了那个人，你必须做另一项工作，成为一名节目主管，这很酷，但你也需要乔·凯利。
I'm sure you have young Joe Kelly's around your table, so I'm too blessed though.
我确信你的桌子旁有年轻的乔·凯利，所以我太幸运了。
And Detroiters, you're like, good, that guy's got energy and he's gonna give me 100 bits.
底特律人队，你会说，很好，那家伙很有活力，他会给我 100 比特。
And I like that.
我喜欢这样。
But also sometimes I have to like say, like, hey, let's focus your children.
但有时我也不得不说，嘿，让我们关注你的孩子。
We got, we got, we got to also remember what the fucking story is, which is the curse of being a showrunner.
我们得到了，我们得到了，我们还必须记住他妈的故事是什么，这是作为剧集主管的诅咒。
Also, it's like the boss.
而且，还像老板一样。
You're like, yes, I'm the third youngest guy in the room, but we got to focus.
你会说，是的，我是房间里第三年轻的人，但我们必须集中注意力。
Yes, that's also awkward.
是的，这也很尴尬。
It's also like, you know, there were, there were some staffing shifts between season one and two, and then two and three.
这也就像，你知道，在第一季和第二季之间，然后是第二季和第三季之间，有一些人员变动。
I mean, there were always kind of moving parts and pieces, but it's kind of interesting you and Carter were like, trying to, you know, you knew you had really strong writers in this area, you needed, you had a little deficiency here.
我的意思是，总是有一些移动的部件和片段，但有趣的是，你和卡特试图，你知道，你知道你在这个领域有非常强大的作家，你需要，你在这里有一点缺陷。
So you would hire based on, you know, like it's a band, you're like, yeah, we need a horn section.
所以你会根据，你知道，就像这是一个乐队，你会说，是的，我们需要一个喇叭部分。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, like we're gonna, we're gonna try to staff this out in a way where, you know.
你知道，就像我们要做的那样，我们会尝试以某种方式来解决这个问题。
Yeah.
是的。
What don't we have in the mix?
我们没有什么？
What sound don't we have in the mix?
混音中没有什么声音？
And I feel like Joe came in and was the perfect guy to write the bracket.
我觉得乔进来了，是编写括号的最佳人选。
Because Joe, Joe loves basketball.
因为乔，乔热爱篮球。
Joe brought me explain to us how brackets work.
乔带我向我们解释括号是如何工作的。
And that's who Carter and I are.
这就是卡特和我。
We're like, what is that again?
我们就像，那又是什么？
I don't understand this sports talk.
我听不懂这个体育谈话。
So this episode was literally almost like a network demanded, like do a March Madness episode.
所以这一集实际上几乎就像网络所要求的那样，就像疯狂三月的剧集一样。
We were giving the network something that had been asking for, I feel, but we wanted to do it in our hymmy way.
我觉得我们正在向网络提供一些一直要求的东西，但我们想以我们谦虚的方式来做。
So we found, it's a mystery, right?
所以我们发现，这是一个谜，对吧？
This is kind of a murder mystery.
这有点像谋杀之谜。
This is kind of who is trying to kill who is killing Barney's chances with women and I love that you don't find out I love that it's a cliffhanger.
这是一种试图杀死巴尼与女人交往的机会的人，我喜欢你没有发现我喜欢这是一个悬念。
You're gonna find out in a later episode It turns out and it turns out to be someone really interesting.
你会在后面的剧集中发现事实证明这是一个非常有趣的人。
Was that always the story?
故事总是这样吗？
I'm trying to remember It felt like that was a last minute twist to be always end it that way, you mean?
我试图回忆起那感觉就像是最后一刻的转折，总是以这种方式结束，你是说？
Yeah Maybe that was the last minute twist because I mean we don't do that many spoilers on this We try to go episode but it turns out to be Britain Britney speed it turns out We're gonna just get that soil, this one.
是的，也许这是最后一分钟的转折，因为我的意思是我们不会在这集上做太多剧透，我们试图继续这一集，但事实证明这是英国布兰妮的速度，事实证明我们只会得到那个土壤，这个。
It turns out to be Britney Spears.
原来是布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。
Maybe we came up with this idea, Joe, because we knew Britney was willing to come back because she had fun in that first episode and we decided, oh, you know, to be funny, if we may have reversed engineered it to that, I can't remember shit.
也许我们想出了这个主意，乔，因为我们知道布兰妮愿意回来，因为她在第一集中玩得很开心，我们决定，哦，你知道，有趣的是，如果我们可以将其逆向工程成那样，我不记得了。
Something about that.
与此有关的一些事情。
This is the old man podcast moment.
这是老人播客时刻。
Every episode of this podcast is a few old man moments.
这个播客的每一集都是一些老人的时刻。
This is one of them.
这是其中之一。
But what is your memory of like, so that's really interesting.
但你的记忆是什么样的，所以这真的很有趣。
I do remember that we wanted to be like, let's get people paid before the strike starts.
我确实记得我们想要这样，让我们​​在罢工开始之前给人们发工资。
I remember that.
我记得。
But was that a completely different idea?
但这是完全不同的想法吗？
I think it was, right?
我想是的，对吧？
It wasn't the bracket.
这不是支架。
It was a completely different idea.
这是一个完全不同的想法。
So when we came back from the strike, I think we had to do produce nine episodes in about 10 and a half, 11 weeks.
因此，当我们从罢工中回来时，我认为我们必须在大约 10 周半即 11 周内制作九集。
That's my memory.
那是我的记忆。
And we did not, this is a proof positive that we did not, we were not very far ahead because this would have been the second one we shot back out of the strike.
我们没有，这证明我们没有，我们并没有领先很多，因为这将是我们从罢工中反击的第二个。
Because we just talked to Sarah Chalk.
因为我们刚刚和莎拉·乔克谈过。
We talked about 10 sessions.
我们谈了10次。
That was the one, the first one back after the strike.
就是那个人，罢工后第一个回来的人。
This was the second one back.
这是第二次回来了。
And so that means, Joe, that I guess we only had 10 sessions past the one that they shot without us, which was a platinum rule.
所以，乔，这意味着，我猜我们只比他们在没有我们的情况下拍摄的会议进行了 10 场会议，这是白金规则。
Remember, we wrote the platinum rule, like pencils down at midnight.
请记住，我们制定了白金规则，就像午夜铅笔一样。
That's it.
就是这样。
I hope they have a good week shooting this without us.
我希望他们在没有我们的情况下拍摄这部电影度过愉快的一周。
The only episode of him you ever shot with no writers involved in anyway.
这是你在没有编剧参与的情况下拍摄的关于他的唯一一集。
And then, so we, Jesus, do you remember what it felt like?
然后，我们，耶稣，你还记得那是什么感觉吗？
Like, okay, the strike is over.
就像，好吧，罢工结束了。
Now we have to come up with an episode idea.
现在我们必须想出一个情节创意。
Let's do this bracket thing.
让我们来做这个括号的事情。
Like, do you remember what that pressure felt like?
比如，你还记得那种压力是什么感觉吗？
Cause that's a lot of pressure for your first sitcom episode you ever wrote and produced.
因为这对于你编写和制作的第一集情景喜剧来说压力很大。
I, cause again, I always start with the, for me, like something that makes me laugh or the comedy hook of it.
我，再次强调，对我来说，我总是从一些让我发笑的东西或它的喜剧钩子开始。
And I remember, I, I, I knew it was March Madness.
我记得，我，我，我知道这是疯狂三月。
And I don't remember what the pitch was, but I remember Jamie Ronheim or pitch something about the bracket and being the bracket.
我不记得投球是什么，但我记得杰米·罗海姆（Jamie Ronheim）或投球有关支架和支架的东西。
And I remember you guys liking it and it'd be, and knowing I was going to write the episode, I remember going, all right, this is going to, this is going to be fun.
我记得你们喜欢它，而且会的，并且知道我要写这一集，我记得去，好吧，这会，这会很有趣。
And I almost instantly just thought, like I forget how we broke and everything, but I just remember like debating between the girls and like fake baby and no, it was this one and that one.
我几乎立刻就想，好像我忘记了我们是如何分手的以及一切，但我只记得就像女孩之间的辩论一样，就像假婴儿一样，不，是这个和那个。
And knowing that would be fun.
知道这一点会很有趣。
And so I was just very like, oh, that'll be fun.
所以我就想，哦，那会很有趣。
And then this will, as long as we can get to that.
只要我们能做到这一点，这就会实现。
And then watching the episode, it was a very him-y-me thing and a very card-and-creg thing.
然后观看这一集，这是一个非常他我的事情，也是一个非常卡牌的事情。
You just work the cast so well.
你把演员阵容演得很好。
To go back to a previous question, when I work with the writers rooms, writers rooms are always, young writers are always pitching for the side characters and new characters, and Carter and Craig were always pitching for their characters, the main cast and finding things for them to do and not falling in love with the day of players and these other people.
回到之前的问题，当我与编剧室合作时，编剧室总是这样，年轻的编剧总是在为配角和新角色做准备，而卡特和克雷格总是在为他们的角色、主要演员做准备，并为他们找事情做，而不是爱上球员和其他人的日子。
And the Lily storyline of making Barney apologize to these women and going along with them was like, It was an underrated Alison Hannigan episode where I just loved them as a couple and her mothering Barney was a runner in the series.
莉莉让巴尼向这些女人道歉并与她们相处的故事情节就像是，这是一个被低估的艾莉森·汉尼根剧集，我只是爱他们作为一对，而她的母亲巴尼是该系列中的跑步者。
It's the redemptive element of the story.
这是故事的救赎元素。
Yeah.
是的。
It's important to have that.
拥有它很重要。
It's something I never would have approached breaking, especially back then.
这是我永远不会去打破的东西，尤其是在那时。
I was like, that's Carter and Craig is taking this outrageous Barney story, but grounding it in this great Lilly and Barney story that's really...
我当时想，卡特和克雷格正在拍摄这个令人发指的巴尼故事，但将其植根于这个伟大的莉莉和巴尼故事，这真的是……
like Barney has a little lily on his shoulder.
就像巴尼肩上有一朵小百合一样。
Like she's sometimes the Jiminy Cricket, you know, for Ted and for Barney.
就像她有时是泰德和巴尼的吉米尼蟋蟀一样。
She is.
她是。
Yeah, that's a great observation, Joe.
是的，这是一个很好的观察，乔。
That's what I thought is really funny.
这就是我认为非常有趣的事情。
It's like, you guys were, there's a line in season, we've talked about this a lot, but it was so funny.
就像，你们，季节有一条线，我们已经谈论了很多，但这太有趣了。
Ted just at one point calls Gail, he calls him the Cadillac of rebound guys.
泰德有一次给盖尔打电话，称他为篮板球界的凯迪拉克。
And my memory was that Cadillac was sponsoring the episode and we had to drop.
我的记忆是凯迪拉克赞助了这一集，我们不得不放弃。
It's true.
这是真的。
We had to name drop like Cadillac in a nice way.
我们必须以一种很好的方式像凯迪拉克那样命名。
So it was like, it was just like product placement, but it was funny how you guys were honoring this thing of like, okay, March Madness, the bracket, but you dispense with the basketball part of it, like immediately, like they are terrible at this.
所以这就像，这就像植入式广告一样，但有趣的是，你们如何尊重这样的事情，好吧，疯狂三月，括号，但你立即放弃了其中的篮球部分，就像他们在这方面很糟糕一样。
The team loss loses immediately, they're out of it.
球队输了就直接输了，他们就出局了。
And then you're just onto this other thing that, but you retain the form.
然后你就开始做另一件事，但你保留了形式。
So it's kind of like, okay, yeah, we'll give you a basketball episode.
所以这有点像，好吧，是的，我们会给你一个篮球节目。
There's not gonna be about basketball.
不会有关于篮球的事情。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And the other thing I like about it, Joe, I think you were really good at writing this tone, which again, Barney is very on the edge of an acceptable human being in this episode, but the lily piece redeems that you're right.
我喜欢的另一件事是，乔，我认为你真的很擅长写这种语气，巴尼在这一集里再次处于一个可接受的人的边缘，但百合花弥补了你是对的。
The other thing is the gang getting really into it or into solving the mystery, the gang getting really into going through the brackets scientifically and really arguing for each team or not.
另一件事是，这帮人真正投入其中或解决这个谜团，这帮人真正科学地通过括号，真正为每个团队争论与否。
And then they're very excited about it while also being horrified.
然后他们对此感到非常兴奋，同时也感到震惊。
And that tone is a great tone, because they're not like, they're not churlish and scolding.
这种语气是一种很好的语气，因为他们不像，他们没有粗鲁和责骂。
They really do get sucked into like the gambling aspect of it.
他们确实像赌博一样陷入了困境。
But then they're also like, also you're a psychopath.
但他们也会说，你也是一个精神病患者。
Like it's a really good, they each have different like eyewitness moments of like, no, no, I saw that one.
就像这真的很好，他们每个人都有不同的目击者时刻，比如，不，不，我看到了那个。
It's fake, baby.
这是假的，宝贝。
Trust me.
相信我。
I was there.
我在那里。
It's one big baby.
已经是一个大宝贝了
It's a great writer's room bit to you to just be able to say and not really know what it means, fake baby.
这是一个伟大的作家的房间，你只能说，但并不真正知道这意味着什么，假宝贝。
You don't see that, you don't really explain it, but just leaving it to the imagination.
你没有看到这一点，你也没有真正解释它，只是把它留给想象。
It's like, Jaws, it's better not to see the shark.
就像，大白鲨，最好不要看到鲨鱼。
I think I remember when we were right, you go and like, do we need to explain fake baby?
我想我记得当我们是对的时候，你会说，我们需要解释假宝贝吗？
And you're like, nah, it's way better, it's way better.
你会说，不，这好多了，好多了。
And that's the right answer.
这就是正确的答案。
I think if you look at all my how much of my other episodes, and later episodes, this was the one I learned to always give seagull lines, because there's a couple of scenes in this where he's just in a group and he's just sitting there nodding and he gave me shit for it every single time.
我想如果你看看我的其他剧集以及后来的剧集，这就是我学会的总是给出海鸥台词的那一集，因为其中有几个场景，他只是在一群人中，他只是坐在那里点头，他每次都给我带来麻烦。
What did he do?
他做了什么？
I was like doing stuff in the scene.
我就像在现场做事一样。
During rehearsals, he would just stare at me.
排练的时候，他只是盯着我看。
And then I was watching the episode.
然后我就在看这一集。
I was just watching him and he's just hamming it up so much when he's just nodding and he doesn't have a line.
我只是看着他，他只是在点点头，而且没有台词，他只是在夸夸其谈。
It's like a protest, protest background acting.
这就像一场抗议，抗议背景的表演。
He's having fun.
他玩得很开心。
Like he didn't sabotage anything.
就像他没有破坏任何事情一样。
He was just poking me, but it really, it was a tough, you always had to find something for each of the people and every little scene of what was often the hardest thing to do.
他只是在戳我，但这真的很艰难，你总是必须为每个人和每个小场景找到一些东西，而这往往是最难做的事情。
But that's really funny.
但这真的很有趣。
And you don't realize you fell to do it until you're watching them.
直到你看到他们时，你才会意识到你已经爱上了这样做。
Until you're out of my soul.
直到你离开我的灵魂。
And then you're like, oh fuck, we totally didn't give him a ride.
然后你就会想，哦操，我们完全没有搭他一程。
You used to have a line, but then we cut it and then moved that up.
你曾经有一条线，但后来我们把它剪掉，然后把它移上去。
Do you remember this thing?
你还记得这件事吗？
There's a clip of Patton Oswalt on King of Queens where he protest background acts because he was in a scene, a big long party scene, and he wasn't given a single line, and it's him standing perfectly still.
帕顿·奥斯瓦尔特在《皇后之王》中有一段片段，他抗议背景表演，因为他身处一个场景，一个大型的长派对场景，没有给他一句台词，而是他一动不动地站着。
As though he is frozen like a statue, like one of the guys, like one of the gold painted guys just enacting it right now.
就好像他像一座雕像一样被冻结，就像其中一个人，就像一个刚刚表演的金色油漆的人。
And he stands away for about like three or four minutes.
他站了大约三四分钟。
And if you watch this scene, you can look this up on YouTube.
如果你观看这个场景，你可以在 YouTube 上查找。
It is a masterclass in protest background acting.
这是抗议背景表演的大师班。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
I love how, I think we talked about this recently, Craig, but like sometimes you have, you're writing from the character's point of view and everyone has a different point of view, like Robin's being very, Robin in this moment and Ted's being very Ted, but there's something joyful when they're all on the same page.
我喜欢，我想我们最近谈论过这个，克雷格，但就像有时你一样，你从角色的角度写作，每个人都有不同的观点，就像罗宾在这一刻非常，罗宾，泰德非常泰德，但当他们都在同一页上时，会有一些快乐的事情。
Yeah, and they're all sucked into this thing.
是的，他们都被这件事吸引了。
They're all like united in this shared project of like figuring this out.
他们都团结在这个共同的项目中，想解决这个问题。
And then, but what I really like is at the end, they're like, they're heartbroken because it's so gross.
然后，但我真正喜欢的是最后，他们就像，他们心碎了，因为这太恶心了。
I mean, this is so sad inside.
我的意思是，内心是如此悲伤。
Yeah, it's like needed that moment too.
是的，那一刻也需要。
We really needed that moment.
我们真的需要那一刻。
Yeah, with Ted says, I just want to call my mom and tell her I love her.
是的，泰德说，我只想打电话给我妈妈，告诉她我爱她。
I want to call my mom.
我想给我妈妈打电话。
You really need those lines to make this whole episode okay?
你真的需要这些台词才能让整个情节顺利吗？
Cause it's so what's that?
因为它就是这样那是什么？
There's a lot of like, pallet cleansing necessary in this episode.
在这一集里有很多像托盘清理这样的必要内容。
Cause it's cause we're not, we're not glorifying this behavior where he does apologize at the end for forgetting one of the women.
因为我们不是，我们不会美化这种行为，他最后会因为忘记其中一个女人而道歉。
He turns out to be wrong about it.
事实证明他的想法是错误的。
but Lily, Lily is proud of him, that he made some like little step of evolution of acknowledging some wrongdoing.
但莉莉，莉莉为他感到骄傲，因为他在承认一些错误行为方面迈出了一小步。
But he is, yes, Barney, Barney is liking a razor's edge in this episode, but God damn it, it is funny.
但他是，是的，巴尼，巴尼在这一集里就像剃刀一样，但该死的，这很有趣。
Well, he's almost like, I feel like it's a virtue of Neil's performance, but it also edges it into more problematic territory, which is like, he never winks.
好吧，他几乎就像，我觉得这是尼尔表演的优点，但这也将其推向了更有问题的领域，就像，他从不眨眼。
Neil never winks in his like, this isn't me.
尼尔从不眨眼，这不是我。
Like he, he's like, he doesn't like, with the commitment of like Anthony Hopkins playing Hannibal Lecter.
就像他一样，他喜欢，他不喜欢，像安东尼·霍普金斯扮演汉尼拔·莱克特那样的承诺。
Like he's like, I'm actually a serial killer and I don't have any apology about this.
就像他说的，我实际上是一个连环杀手，对此我没有任何道歉。
Big overlaps to American Psycho.
与《美国精神病人》有很大重叠。
We were talking about American Psycho a lot while making him, and we were like, Barney's really, he's, he's, he's, he's a cousin of this.
在制作《美国精神病人》的过程中，我们经常谈论他，我们说，巴尼真的，他，他，他，他是这个的表弟。
At least.
至少。
Yeah.
是的。
I was, there's a thing online where they keep asking like, how was, was Kramer on Seinfeld?
我是，网上有一个问题，他们一直在问，克莱默在《宋飞正传》上怎么样？
Was he rich or not?
他到底有钱还是没钱？
Cause in this episode, he can afford all this, this.
因为在这一集里，他可以承受这一切，这一切。
In this episode, he doesn't have any money.
在这一集中，他没有钱。
And I was like, guys, when you make this many episodes, you're just always trying to come up with the funniest thing.
我当时想，伙计们，当你们制作这么多集时，你们总是试图想出最有趣的事情。
Right.
正确的。
And it's just none of this happened.
而这一切都没有发生。
Yeah.
是的。
It's not a documentary.
这不是一部纪录片。
I'll make them up.
我会弥补它们。
Yeah.
是的。
No one was hurt.
没有人受伤。
It's all crazy to make them up.
编造它们真是太疯狂了。
But we also, there's a thing like when we've noticed that when Barney gets too gross or too unrepentant, there's always, there's a come up and he gets that you guys would give him that I think keeps him at the booth with everyone.
但我们也有这样的事情，当我们注意到巴尼变得太粗鲁或太顽固时，总会有一个问题出现，他知道你们会给他，我认为这让他和每个人一起呆在展位上。
Yeah.
是的。
I think it allows him to stay at the booth.
我认为这可以让他留在展位上。
Yeah, I think Joe's exactly right.
是的，我认为乔说得完全正确。
Like in this episode, Barney needed to have actually hooked up with a lot of women and other episodes, it's clear he strikes out a huge percentage of the time, which is the truth.
就像在这一集中，巴尼实际上需要与很多女人和其他剧集发生联系，很明显他在很大一部分时间里都失败了，这是事实。
It is his Kramer, Richard, not.
这是他的克莱默，理查德，不是。
It really is whatever you need that week kind of.
这确实是您那周需要的任何东西。
Was it ever said on the show, how many women he slept with?
节目里有没有说过他睡过多少个女人？
I forget if we ever said it.
我忘记我们是否说过这句话。
I think we probably avoided saying that.
我想我们可能避免这么说。
I know, I think that was the answer because it was a real, I remember debating how much of it is talked about it.
我知道，我认为这就是答案，因为它是真实的，我记得争论了多少内容。
He definitely talked about it, yeah, but he strikes out a huge amount of the time.
是的，他确实谈到了这一点，但他很多时候都三振了。
This is the most success he's appeared to have had.
这是他迄今为止取得的最成功的一次。
This is the episode that seems to indicate he really did it.
这一集似乎表明他确实做到了。
He did hook up with a bunch of women.
他确实勾搭了一群女人。
There's a lot of brackets on there.
上面有很多括号。
And maybe this is like, maybe he made some of those up, even though it's...
也许这就像，也许他编造了其中一些，尽管这是......
Maybe this is weak sauce come up, but he gets slapped a lot in this series and in this episode in particular.
也许这是弱酱出现，但他在这个系列中，特别是在这一集里被打了很多耳光。
He gets physically abused in the episode.
他在这一集中受到身体虐待。
We needed all of that.
我们需要这一切。
We needed all of that to, like, even earn this happening, you know, this episode, like, existing.
我们需要所有这些，甚至赢得这一切的发生，你知道，这一集，就像，存在。
And this old man, he must admit he fell in love with you, new York City.
而这个老人，他必须承认他爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to Shell.
回到壳牌。
People love this one.
人们喜欢这个。
This is considered a classic.
这被认为是经典。
I think some people probably hate Barney in this and are like, this is an example of an episode of where we don't like Barney.
我想有些人可能讨厌巴尼，他们会说，这是我们不喜欢巴尼的一个例子。
Some people are like, this is my Barney episode.
有些人会说，这是我的巴尼剧集。
And I'm all in.
我全力以赴。
And I would argue that we maybe needed this at this moment.
我认为我们现在可能需要这个。
This was coming out of the strike.
这是罢工造成的。
This was episode two that was going to air coming out of the strike.
这是罢工后即将播出的第二集。
The first one was 10 sessions with Sarah chalk.
第一个是与 Sarah chalk 的 10 次会议。
I think, am I right about this show?
我想，我对这个节目的看法是对的吗？
I think I'm getting this right.
我想我做对了。
And 10 sessions is the sweetest romantic comedy, two-minute date, like super gooey heartfelt, like the hymnium rom-com, and in purist and under an adulterated form, this next one shows you this completely other thing that the show can do.
《十场戏》是最甜蜜的浪漫喜剧，两分钟的约会，就像超级粘稠的衷心，就像赞美诗浪漫喜剧，以纯粹主义和掺假的形式，下一部向您展示了该剧可以做的完全不同的事情。
And I don't know if you remember this feeling, Joe, but I think we all felt like we just sat around for three months wondering if we were gonna be unemployed at the end of it.
我不知道你是否记得这种感觉，乔，但我想我们都感觉我们只是坐了三个月，想知道我们最终是否会失业。
We got to sing for our supper here, and we got to show everything.
我们必须在这里为我们的晚餐唱歌，我们必须展示一切。
So we just talked about with Sarah Chock, how like Britney Spears, the two minute date, like we came in a hot with that one.
所以我们刚刚和莎拉·乔克（Sarah Chock）谈论了如何像布兰妮·斯皮尔斯（Britney Spears）那样，两分钟的约会，就像我们对那个人很感兴趣。
And then this one was like, This is the barniest, Barney can ever Barney, and we're just gonna do it and remind you that it also does this.
然后这个就像是，这是最巴尼的，巴尼可以是巴尼，我们只是要做并提醒你它也这样做。
And that whole back nine of that season that was produced in record breaking time, we've never worked with that limited amount of time, there's a lot of good ones.
那个赛季的整个后九场比赛都是在破纪录的时间内完成的，我们从来没有在这么有限的时间内工作过，有很多好的时间。
There's a lot of, we put it this way, we took big swings and we had no time to overthink it, right?
有很多，我们这样说，我们做出了很大的波动，我们没有时间去想太多，对吧？
You had to write this in about two seconds, I'm thinking Joe, usually you would have had a week and then you turn it into a draft and we give you some notes, you go back out for a few days.
你必须在大约两秒钟内写完这个，我想乔，通常你会花一周的时间，然后你把它变成草稿，我们给你一些笔记，你回去几天。
Do you remember what it was like?
你还记得那是什么样子吗？
We must have given you three days to write the first draft and you have to have it in by Wednesday.
我们必须给你三天时间来写初稿，你必须在周三之前提交。
I mean, what was it?
我的意思是，那是什么？
Do you remember?
你是否记得？
I don't remember and I always, I always liked Disney's, we need this tonight, like I was before that.
我不记得了，我总是，我一直喜欢迪士尼，我们今晚需要这个，就像我之前一样。
Yeah, no, it can be a real good thing.
是的，不，这可能是一件真正的好事。
That pressure can be a real creative.
这种压力可以成为真正的创造力。
A hundred percent.
百分之一百。
Yeah, because like you said, it just takes the doubt.
是的，因为就像你说的，这只是需要怀疑。
You have no time for doubt.
你没有时间怀疑。
You gotta go forward.
你必须向前走。
Do you guys think someone would have to, I bet some hymium fan could do this, but like to do the math on this, I thought it was an incredibly long cold open.
你们认为有人必须这样做吗？我打赌一些 hymium 粉丝可以做到这一点，但喜欢对此进行数学计算，我认为这是一个令人难以置信的长时间冷开。
Did you notice that?
你注意到了吗？
Like when the credit song comes in, you're like, oh, wow, we haven't even started.
就像当片尾曲响起时，你会想，哦，哇，我们还没开始呢。
Like usually you don't do that.
就像通常你不这样做一样。
It's really long.
真的很长。
It was really long.
I forgot.
我忘了。
I was like, do we not have main titles in this one?
我当时想，我们这个没有主要标题吗？
And then it's like, oh, there it is.
然后就好像，哦，就在那里。
Yeah, no.
是的，不。
And then an all-time or tag, too.
然后也是历史或标签。
Do you remember this joke when it came up with this tag?
当这个标签出现时，你还记得这个笑话吗？
I remember being very excited when, I don't know whose idea was like, I'm getting it.
我记得当时我非常兴奋，我不知道是谁的想法，我明白了。
I think it may have been my pitch because I remember I pitched it, and then immediately said, I've got to go call Neil right now, because we shouldn't bother writing this.
我认为这可能是我的推销，因为我记得我推销了它，然后立即说，我现在必须打电话给尼尔，因为我们不应该费心写这个。
And let's get attached to it unless we give it approval.
除非我们批准它，否则我们就依附于它。
We have to go, and I never would do this.
我们必须走了，我永远不会这样做。
I don't know that I've ever done this to Josh.
我不知道我曾经对乔希做过这样的事。
I called the second, we were pitching out, and I said stop, and I walked out, I called him, I was like, here's the bit.
我打电话给第二个，我们正在投球，我说停止，然后我走了出去，我打电话给他，我想，这就是一点。
It's a doogie-houser reference.
这是一个 doogie-houser 参考。
It's only gonna happen if you are okay with this bit.
只有当你对此感到满意时才会发生。
And he looked to God bless him.
他仰望上帝保佑他。
and he was like, that's funny, do it.
他说，这很有趣，就这么做吧。
And it got...
它得到了...
Do you know what it reminded me of a little bit?
你知道这让我想起了什么吗？
Do you know, this is a Chris and Phil thing, but in 21 Jump Street, I heard this story and we have to confirm this with him, but I think it's true that Johnny Depp agreed to do a guest spot in the movie, but on the condition that they would kill him.
你知道吗，这是克里斯和菲尔的事情，但在《跳街21号》中，我听到了这个故事，我们必须与他确认这一点，但我认为约翰尼·德普确实同意在电影中客串，但条件是他们要杀了他。
That's 100% true.
这是100%正确的。
I've talked about this with Chris and Phil many times.
我已经多次与克里斯和菲尔讨论过这个问题。
Yeah, that was his insistence.
是的，这就是他的坚持。
And there's something about the Neil, Like he's so, it's a wink and a nod to this past role, but it's so like, he's also killing the characters, like he's killing the characters in a certain way.
尼尔身上有一些东西，就像他一样，这是对过去角色的眨眼和点头，但它也很像，他也在杀死角色，就像他以某种方式杀死角色一样。
It also reminded me of one of my favorite things I've ever seen on TV is in Arrested Development, Henry Winkler as that lawyer.
这也让我想起我在电视上看到的最喜欢的事情之一是《发展受阻》，亨利·温克勒饰演那位律师。
And he's in the bathroom and the guy leaves and he looks in the mirror and he's about to fix his hair, but then he does.
他在浴室里，那家伙离开了，他照了照镜子，正要整理头发，但随后他就这么做了。
Like he does the fawns in the mirror and it's so fast.
就像他对镜子里的小鹿一样，而且速度非常快。
It's like a minute, it's less than a second, but it's just, it's such a like little insiders like, I don't know, it's like a kiss on the forehead or something.
就像一分钟，不到一秒，但它只是，就像小内部人士一样，我不知道，就像在额头上亲吻什么的。
It's just like the smallest little grace note that's so funny.
就像最小的装饰音一样，非常有趣。
Did you hear the story of the original Fonzie hair thing?
你听说过 Fonzie 头发最初的故事吗？
Cause at the time, having the biker guy comb in his hair was like such an overdone thing.
因为在当时，让骑自行车的家伙梳理头发是一件过分的事情。
Henry Winkler was like, I'm not combing my hair.
亨利·温克勒说，我不梳头。
I'm not gonna do that.
我不会那样做。
It's been done to death, it's a trope, whatever.
它已经被搞死了，这是一个比喻，无论如何。
And they're like, oh, for the opening credits, we need you to call me a hare.
他们就像，哦，对于片头，我们需要你叫我兔子。
It's like, I'm not going to do it.
就像，我不会这样做。
Like we know we're here, and so he's the one who came up with, I don't need to touch it.
就像我们知道我们在这里一样，所以他是想出这个主意的人，我不需要碰它。
It's perfect.
太完美了。
Wow.
哇。
That's so good.
那太好了。
I'm not calling my fucking hare.
我不会叫我该死的兔子。
I'm sick of seeing that.
我厌倦了看到这个。
That's when you realize that the actors become writers of a company, right?
那时你就会意识到演员成为了公司的编剧，对吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
It's totally true.
这是完全正确的。
And they're totally creating this role, you know?
他们完全是在创造这个角色，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And the defenders of the character.
以及角色的捍卫者。
And like, this is what the character would do.
就像，这就是角色会做的事情。
and I think that's good.
我认为这很好。
I'm sure some writers don't feel threatened when actors do that, but I think that's right.
我确信当演员这样做时，有些作家不会感到受到威胁，但我认为这是对的。
There were moments where you'd come and you'd say, I'm worried about Ted.
有时你会过来说，我担心特德。
Ted's been taking a lot of fucking shrapnel lately and I think we need to see Ted be cool again.
特德最近吃了很多该死的弹片，我想我们需要看到特德再次冷静下来。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
You're right, dude.
你是对的，伙计。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But again, it's like in the fog of writer's room war where it's like you got 24 episodes or 10 episodes in nine weeks, like you literally lose the plot sometimes.
但同样，这就像在编剧室战争的迷雾中，你在九周内完成了 24 集或 10 集，就像有时你真的失去了情节一样。
Like I imagine you're just like, Wait, is, you know, I mean, there's, there's so many, that's where you have like the writers assistant who kind of become like the external hard drive where you're like, what is, you know, remind us, you know, sometimes it's like, you guys did this story already, like, it is a blur and it was never more of a blur than these nine episodes in 10 and a half weeks.
就像我想象的那样，等等，是，你知道，我的意思是，有，有很多，这就是你的编剧助理，他有点像外部硬盘驱动器，你知道，提醒我们，你知道，有时就像，你们已经完成了这个故事，就像，这是一个模糊，而且从来没有比这十周半的九集更模糊的了。
This was, yeah, this way, you really had a crazy, you joined at a weird moment, Joe, But I had nothing to compare to.
是的，这样，你真的很疯狂，你在一个奇怪的时刻加入，乔，但我没有什么可以比较的。
You don't compare it to.
你不比较它。
This is it.
就是这样。
Let's go.
我们走吧。
This is what it is.
就是这样。
Isn't it funny that you thought the good old days of the first two seasons were never the glory days that you were never going to be.
你认为前两季的美好时光从来都不是你永远不会成为的辉煌岁月，这不是很有趣吗？
That lightsaber battle.
那场光剑之战。
I know.
我知道。
I was so mad.
我很生气。
Get it.
得到它。
Stop reminiscing about this fucking lightsaber battle nerd.
别再回忆这个该死的光剑战斗书呆子了。
You know what's funny?
你知道什么好笑吗？
We know it's really made me and Jordan and my wife laugh.
我们知道这真的让我、乔丹和我的妻子开怀大笑。
Kobe's giggling when lying.
科比撒谎时会咯咯地笑。
It's a fight.
这是一场战斗。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And that is such a Joe line.
这就是乔的台词。
guaranteed that was your land.
保证那是你的土地。
The thing, the thing where it's, have you ever fallen asleep eating ribs?
那个东西，那个东西在哪里，你吃过排骨睡着过吗？
Now, I feel like that was in your first draft and never change.
现在，我觉得那是你的初稿，永远不会改变。
That was my hardest laugh of the whole episode.
这是整集里我笑得最厉害的一次。
And Rebecca too, by the way.
顺便说一下，丽贝卡也是。
An old friend of mine, his wife, and who was also my friend fell asleep while eating ribs.
我的一个老朋友，他的妻子，也是我的朋友，吃排骨的时候睡着了。
So you never know what thing came from real.
所以你永远不知道什么东西是真实的。
That way you would not guess that that's the thing from real life in this episode.
这样你就不会猜到这就是本集中现实生活中的事情。
Well, it's so weird.
嗯，这太奇怪了。
It's like it has to be like, it's so strange.
就好像它必须是这样，这太奇怪了。
But it's also that way in your brain and you're like, I'm going to use that detail someday.
但你的大脑中也是这样，你会想，有一天我会使用这个细节。
It's also such a, it's such a funny playable thing to give an actor.
也是这样一个，给演员一个这么搞笑可玩的东西。
Yeah, you know, Kobe was very funny with that laughing while lying.
是的，你知道，科比撒谎时笑起来非常有趣。
That was a great, that was a JK draft one, like that bit, that whole idea, those lines right in there.
那太棒了，那是 JK 草案，就像那一点，整个想法，那些台词就在那里。
I mean, your SNL roots probably prepared you not to panic to have to write something really fucking fast.
我的意思是，你的《周六夜现场》根基可能会让你不必惊慌地写出一些非常他妈的快的东西。
I would wager, right?
我敢打赌，对吧？
I would just say, and putting stuff up on its feet, you performing and stuff.
我只想说，把东西站起来，你表演等等。
I remember you were not daunted by how fast this had to move.
我记得你并没有被事情进展得如此之快而吓倒。
Yeah, yes.
是的，是的。
I guess so with SNL.
我想《周六夜现场》也是如此。
But also, I just remember at Boom Chicago on Amsterdam, you played these games where you had to come up with a joke and sometimes you would just call sing a thing and you would walk to the mic because the last guy just finished and you'd have to And I just knew I had, until I got to the mic to come up with something.
而且，我只记得在阿姆斯特丹的 Boom Chicago，你玩这些游戏，你必须想出一个笑话，有时你只是叫唱一个东西，然后你会走到麦克风前，因为最后一个人刚刚结束，你必须这样做，我就知道我已经做到了，直到我走到麦克风前想出一些东西。
I would just go up there like I had an idea and maybe take my time a little bit.
我会像有一个想法一样去那里，也许会花点时间。
But I'm like, oh yeah, I got something.
但我想，哦，是的，我得到了一些东西。
But yeah, I think more of the boom Chicago days of like, you know, but you got from here to there.
但是，是的，我更多地想到芝加哥的繁荣时期，你知道，但你从这里到那里。
But that's good training, man.
但这是很好的训练，伙计。
It's been training and you want that guy in the room.
这是在训练，你希望那个人在房间里。
And I think you carry that into the room.
我想你要把它带进房间。
You were also very good at like knowing that a writer's room did need like morale.
你也很擅长知道作家的房间确实需要士气。
You would bring in like langers, like the Stromi sandwiches for everybody.
你会为每个人带来像朗格、斯特罗米三明治这样的东西。
You were the guy who was like, we need a basketball hoop out back, right?
你就是那个说，我们需要一个篮球筐的人，对吧？
I think that basketball hoop got out in the back of parking lot outside of our office.
我认为篮球筐是从我们办公室外面停车场后面掉出来的。
I think because of you, I mean, if it wasn't because of you, you definitely have the money behind it.
我认为是因为你，我的意思是，如果不是因为你，你背后肯定有钱。
But you like champion, you're like at lunch, we're all gonna go shoot, like we're gonna, like lunch is, you eat lunch, and then you go shoot hoops.
但你喜欢冠军，你就像在午餐时，我们都会去投篮，就像我们要去的那样，就像午餐一样，你吃午餐，然后你去投篮。
I'm like, you brought that energy to the show.
我想，你给演出带来了这种能量。
And I bet, I don't know, I bet my suspicion is that as a showrunner, like did you do, is that what you try to do when you're a showrunner now?
我敢打赌，我不知道，我敢打赌我的怀疑是，作为一个节目主持人，就像你所做的那样，这就是你现在作为节目主持人时尝试做的事情吗？
I haven't worked, I haven't been in your room where you're a showrunner, are you all, are you making sure that everyone's like remembering it's supposed to be fun?
我没有工作，我没有去过你们担任节目主持人的房间，你们确保每个人都记得这应该很有趣吗？
Cause you were good at that on him, yum.
因为你对他很擅长，嗯。
No, yeah, I was not, I was not a good as a showrunner where I was just in charge of it.
不，是的，我不是，我不是一个优秀的制片人，我只是负责它。
I was like, it's hard to remember that part, right?
我当时想，很难记住那部分，对吧？
Yeah, we got shit to do, we got shit to do.
是的，我们有很多事情要做，我们有很多事情要做。
That was, and that was me.
那是，那是我。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
Can we beat this?
我们能打败这个吗？
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Can this be better?
这可以更好吗？
So yeah, I enjoy, and first season, I said lasso, I was the Hemium Joe, because Bill Lawrence was the one moving us forward, and I was just throwing ideas.
所以，是的，我喜欢，第一季，我说套索，我是 Hemium Joe，因为比尔·劳伦斯是推动我们前进的人，而我只是提出想法。
I was just doing, I had the sweet, what I call the Rob Greenberg, which is where you come in two days, two, three days a week.
我只是在做，我吃了甜食，我称之为罗布·格林伯格，你每周两天、两天、三天都会来这里。
Oh, that was you on the first season of flapsop?
哦，那是你在《flapsop》第一季的时候吗？
I didn't realize you weren't full-time, okay.
我不知道你不是全职的，好吧。
Pitch, pitch, pitch, pitch, pitch, and then go away.
投球，投球，投球，投球，投球，然后消失。
And it was one of the better years of my life.
那是我一生中最美好的时光之一。
and I was much better at that.
我在这方面做得更好。
But then in later seasons, you were a co-show runner or a show running?
但在后来的几季中，你是一名联合节目主持人还是一名节目主持人？
What happened?
发生了什么？
You were running the room, yeah.
是的，你在管理房间。
You were running the room.
你负责管理房间。
At all, Jason was the bottom of the funnel and everything that happened.
无论如何，杰森是漏斗的底部以及所发生的一切。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
What about Detroiters?
底特律人呢？
Were you, did you have a co-show runner on that?
你有联合节目主持人吗？
Or was that the UN, those guys?
或者那些家伙就是联合国？
It was just, it was very much the four, me, Tim, Sam and Zack Cannon.
只是，很大程度上是四个人，我、蒂姆、萨姆和扎克·坎农。
As a, I think I was probably top build on the credits or whatever, but we just moved as a four-person entity.
作为一个，我认为我可能是在积分或其他什么的基础上建立的，但我们只是作为一个四人实体移动。
And writers came into the room and laughed, but it was always up.
作家们走进房间大笑，但气氛总是高涨。
That show was so funny.
那个节目太搞笑了。
If anyone listening has not watched the Troiders, give that a watch.
如果听的人还没有看过 Troiders，请观看。
That is such a funny show.
那真是一个有趣的节目。
Yeah, it keeps bouncing around streaming services.
是的，它一直在流媒体服务中跳跃。
It's so good.
太好了。
And you have, Joe, I want to also, while we're just plugging JK stuff here, you have a movie coming out or it's out.
你有，乔，我也想，当我们只是在这里插入 JK 的东西时，你有一部电影要上映或者已经上映了。
By the time this podcast drops, it will be out, right?
到这个播客消失的时候，它就会消失，对吗？
Tell us, give us a quick pitch.
告诉我们，给我们一个快速的推介。
Let's plug your movie.
让我们插入您的电影。
Office romance, Jennifer Lopez, how much your mother's Jennifer Lopez?
办公室恋情，詹妮弗·洛佩兹，你妈妈的詹妮弗·洛佩兹多少钱？
How much your audience, that's what she's really known for, yeah.
你的观众有多少，这就是她真正出名的原因，是的。
And did you talk about that even once with her?
你和她谈过一次吗？
When you were working with her, and we were like, hey, remember doing how much?
当你和她一起工作时，我们就像，嘿，记得做了多少？
No, thanks though.
不，不过还是谢谢。
I would.
我会的。
Wait, the movies called Office romance?
等等，叫《办公室恋情》的电影？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Okay, yeah, yeah.
好吧，是啊，是啊。
I don't know if you're pitching it or is it?
不知道你是在推销还是真的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
It's Goldstein, and you and Brett, you and Brett co-wrote it, right?
这是戈德斯坦，你和布雷特，你和布雷特共同写的，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
We were sitting on a, we're on a train from Manchester to London, a film in the Manchester episode of Lasso, and as he should do a romantic comedy, he was like, who would you, if you do a romantic comedy then who would it be?
我们坐在从曼彻斯特到伦敦的火车上，电影《套索》的曼彻斯特情节，当他应该拍一部浪漫喜剧时，他说，你会选择谁，如果你拍一部浪漫喜剧，那会是谁？
And he was like, so fast that Jennifer Lopez, I was like, he said it's so fast, I was like, oh, really?
他说，太快了，詹妮弗·洛佩兹，我说，他说太快了，我说，哦，真的吗？
He's like, yes.
他说，是的。
And pitched him by the time the train hit London, we had talked through the beats of the whole movie that are like pretty close to what ended up being this is reminiscent of the nine episodes in 11 weeks.
当火车抵达伦敦时，我们就向他推销了整部电影的节奏，这些节奏非常接近最终的结果，让人想起11周内的9集。
You were using those same skills of like we're just getting this done right here.
您正在使用相同的技能，就像我们刚刚在这里完成这项工作一样。
I wish I had the numbers because I have I took a picture of the train ticket and within a year and a half I was coming home from making that movie.
我希望我有这些数字，因为我拍了一张火车票的照片，一年半之内我就拍完那部电影回家了。
That's insane.
那太疯狂了。
That never ever happens.
这种事永远不会发生。
It was it was it was the the Jennifer Lopez machine of like she loved it.
这是詹妮弗·洛佩兹的机器，就像她喜欢的那样。
She believed in it.
她相信这一点。
She had a gap in her schedule, and we're doing this in February, and her and her manager, Elaine, it was like, we're doing it.
她的日程安排有间隙，我们在二月份做这件事，她和她的经理伊莱恩就好像我们正在做这件事。
This is happening.
这正在发生。
And I was, it was just like along for the ride.
而我，就像是一起旅行。
It was great.
太棒了。
That's awesome.
You've done so much cool stuff since having much of my mother, my friend.
自从有了我母亲、我的朋友之后，你已经做了很多很酷的事情。
You have, I'm very proud of how much cool shit the hymnum writers have gone to get down on what they've gone on to do.
你有，我为赞美诗作者们对他们所做的事情进行了如此多的酷狗屎而感到自豪。
It's very cool.
非常酷。
We learned well and then you go off, I remember working on the scripts and how much mother was always just so much fun, it was such a great room, it was just like a murderous row of like, every day you had to bring it, there was no like off phase, it was a great environment to be in and with the manner writers it was always like a different mix when we split up the rooms.
我们学得很好，然后你就走了，我记得在写剧本时，妈妈总是那么有趣，那是一个很棒的房间，就像一排凶残的一排，每天你都必须带着它，没有类似的休息阶段，这是一个很棒的环境，随着编剧的方式，当我们分开房间时，它总是像一个不同的组合。
two rooms all the time.
一直都是两个房间。
So it was always mixing.
所以它总是混合在一起。
I'll be mixing match.
我会混合比赛。
We weren't who hasn't been in a room together in a while.
我们不是已经有一段时间没有一起呆在一个房间里的人了。
Okay.
好的。
Let's mix.
让我们混合一下。
Let's shuffle the deck.
让我们洗牌吧。
Did you ever Joe win over Steven Lloyd?
你有没有乔赢过史蒂文·劳埃德？
Did he stop doing the before in his way?
他不再按照以前的方式做事了吗？
He would still always use me to demonstrate his martial arts moves.
他还是经常拿我来演示他的武功动作。
He learned that day.
那天他学会了。
Joe, stand here and I'm going to punch and miss you by an half an inch.
乔，站在这里，我就要打你，差你半英寸。
And you're Stephen Lloyd is a very like sort of, what would you say, like a very sophisticated kind of writer.
斯蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd）是一位非常像一位非常老练的作家。
He's very like, he went to Yale, he's a writer's writer, kind of he came from me and his dad was a writer.
他非常喜欢，他去了耶鲁大学，他是一位作家中的作家，有点像他来自我，他的父亲是一位作家。
Like I just dad wrote for tea, legendary TV writer, he came from this long lineage and he would have been a nice button down and very put together and be pitching these very area diet, very like verbose, like interestingly worded.
就像我爸爸为茶写的那样，传奇电视作家，他来自这个悠久的血统，他会是一个很好的保守者，非常团结，并且会推销这些非常区域的饮食，非常冗长，措辞有趣。
Joe's about murder.
乔的目的是谋杀。
I'm often about murder with this dark tinge.
我经常带着这种黑暗的色彩来谈论谋杀。
And then Joe would be like in cargo shorts, eating like a langers.
然后乔就会像穿着工装短裤一样，吃得像个兰格。
And like he'd be sweaty from having just shot hoops.
就像他刚刚投篮时会出汗一样。
He'd be like, who's Barney fucking this week?
他会说，巴尼这周他妈的是谁？
And you guys were like the fucking odd couple when you sit next to each other.
当你们坐在一起时，你们就像一对奇怪的情侣。
And it was, the room needed all of that is my point.
确实，房间需要所有这些，这就是我的观点。
The room needed all of those energies.
这个房间需要所有这些能量。
Every one of my scripts, I just know the Stephen, the Stephen Lloyd lines just ring like a bell.
我的每一个剧本，我只知道斯蒂芬、斯蒂芬·劳埃德的台词就像铃声一样响起。
This is so tight.
这太紧了。
I'm so grateful for everyone.
我非常感谢大家。
I was that Stephen Lloyd, that Stephen Lloyd.
我就是那个斯蒂芬·劳埃德，那个斯蒂芬·劳埃德。
And I remember he would describe the Frasier room because our room was like, it was just people screaming and bouncing off the walls and shooting basketball and just everything.
我记得他会描述弗雷泽房间，因为我们的房间就像，只是人们尖叫、从墙上弹跳、投篮等等。
And he described the Frasier writers' room as like 10 minutes of silence.
他形容《弗雷泽》编剧室里沉默了 10 分钟。
Someone pitching in a quiet voice, the line, the really, really funny line that made it into the show and was hilarious, like a gut-busting line just in a calm voice.
有人用安静的声音进行演讲，这句台词，非常非常有趣的台词出现在节目中，非常搞笑，就像平静的声音中的一句令人心碎的台词。
And everyone nodding like, yes, very good.
每个人都点头说，是的，非常好。
I was like, I couldn't work on Frasier for many weeks, and that was the main one.
我当时想，我有好几个星期都不能在《欢乐一家亲》中工作，而这是主要的。
Or maybe it was Rob Greenberg, I forgot.
或者也许是罗布·格林伯格，我忘了。
But yeah, yeah, I was all energy.
但是，是的，是的，我充满了活力。
The other great thing about this episode is it's a mystery.
这一集的另一个伟大之处在于它是一个谜。
We keep on talking about the thing we're realizing as we go back through the show is how many And like, Hemium writ large, the series is a mystery kind of, and then some of the best Hemiums were in miniature little mini mysteries.
我们继续谈论当我们回顾这部剧时我们意识到的事情是有多少，就像，Hemium 写得很大，这个系列是一个神秘的类型，然后一些最好的 Hemium 是在微型的迷你神秘中。
And this one was, who is sabotaging Barney?
这是，谁在破坏巴尼？
And you actually don't get to find out at the end of this one.
事实上，你在这一篇的结尾并不会找到答案。
You have to keep watching to find out, which was another like, stay tuned.
你必须继续观察才能找到答案，这又是另一回事，敬请期待。
We really want a lot of people to watch season nine, see the back nine episodes of season three, I should say, and we really want to not get canceled coming out of the strike.
我应该说，我们真的希望很多人观看第九季，观看第三季的后九集，而且我们真的不想因为罢工而被取消。
And I think it was fun to write that little mystery, right?
我认为写这个小谜团很有趣，对吧？
they are solving a mystery in this episode.
他们正在解开这一集中的一个谜团。
And I was like, that's something you took too very well as two.
我当时想，这是你两个人都接受得很好的事情。
I feel like you like mysteries too, you're like, yeah.
我觉得你也喜欢神秘，是的。
I was, I was, we had my dad, loved Sherlock Holmes.
我是，我是，我们有我的父亲，爱夏洛克·福尔摩斯。
We watched all the, was that PBS show?
我们都看了，那是 PBS 的节目吗？
All the dads, love Sherlock Holmes.
所有的爸爸都喜欢夏洛克·福尔摩斯。
We would talk about this.
我们会讨论这个。
I remember you liking the mystery thing.
我记得你喜欢神秘的东西。
And I really do love mystery.
我真的很喜欢神秘。
I read, you know, Harry Bosch, Jack Reacher, whatever it is, I love a crime novel.
我读过，你知道，哈利·博斯、杰克·雷彻，不管是什么，我喜欢犯罪小说。
And, and, and combining comedy romance and crime, Like it really was the perfect place for me.
而且，还有，结合喜剧浪漫和犯罪，就像它真的是我的完美地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Was this the first time, I don't think this was the first time we dropped a website that we then made an active website of TedMoseby as a jerk.com.
这是第一次吗？我认为这不是我们第一次放弃一个网站，然后将 TedMoseby 的活跃网站改名为 jerk.com。
Yeah.
是的。
And God, Alec, as you're listening, our pretty shot glove, type this in at TedMoseby as your direct.com and see if there's any world where it's still up.
天哪，亚历克，当你在听的时候，我们漂亮的射击手套，在 TedMoseby 作为你的 direct.com 上输入这个，看看是否有任何世界仍然存在。
I don't think it still is.
我认为现在仍然不是。
But when you went there.
但当你去那里的时候。
For years, it was active.
多年来，它一直很活跃。
It was active and Carter Bay is with the help of Charlene Amoya who played Winnie the Waitress did an insane 15 minute long song called Ted Mosby is a jerk.
它很活跃，卡特贝在扮演女服务员温妮的夏琳·阿莫亚的帮助下创作了一首长达 15 分钟的疯狂歌曲，名为《泰德·莫斯比是个混蛋》。
That was like a piece of weird performance art.
这就像一件奇怪的行为艺术。
It really, what they really made a song, where it's a woman singing something psychotic about Ted Mosby, who's actually Barney.
确实，他们真正创作了一首歌，其中一个女人唱着一些关于特德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）的疯狂歌曲，而特德·莫斯比实际上是巴尼（Barney）。
And it was really something to experience.
这确实是值得体验的事情。
It was really like a performance art.
这真的就像一种行为艺术。
If it's not still in existence there, Alec, maybe we can find it somewhere.
如果它不在那里了，亚历克，也许我们可以在某个地方找到它。
I think it is on a streaming service.
我认为它是在流媒体服务上。
A music streaming service has it somewhere.
音乐流媒体服务在某个地方有它。
We should will link it in the show notes because it truly needs to be listened to.
我们应该将其链接到演出笔记中，因为它确实需要被聆听。
It's insane and fun, great.
这既疯狂又有趣，太棒了。
Ted Mosby is a jerk.com will now take you to Hulu.
Ted Mosby 是个混蛋。com 现在将带您访问 Hulu。
How to make your mother.
如何让你的母亲。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
All right, you know what we should do?
好吧，你知道我们应该做什么吗？
We should talk to Hulu about getting those things going again.
我们应该与 Hulu 讨论如何让这些事情重新开始。
But that song, Alec, find it.
但这首歌，亚历克，找到了。
It's on Spotify or Apple Music.
它位于 Spotify 或 Apple Music 上。
Ted Mosby is a jerk, the song.
泰德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）是个混蛋，这首歌。
I swear, I think that is active.
我发誓，我认为那是活跃的。
Because that pops up sometimes for me on some music checks or something.
因为有时我会在一些音乐检查或其他东西上出现这种情况。
So we can probably link them to show notes.
所以我们或许可以将它们链接起来以显示注释。
It's worth listening to.
值得一听。
really, really genuinely crazy.
真的真的真的很疯狂。
I remember I watched the episode that, where it gets solved, I'm not gonna spoil it.
我记得我看过这一集，当问题得到解决时，我不会破坏它。
And there's a website and that one too, when I go, I chuck you.
还有一个网站，当我去的时候，我就把你甩了。
And I just remember, like, oh yeah, I remember that was the year.
我只记得，哦，是的，我记得那一年。
We got really into that.
我们真的很投入。
I think it was a directive of like, you know, it was just- This internet thing is just- Patching on.
我认为这是一个指令，你知道，这只是 - 这个互联网的东西只是 - 修补。
And then something went in there.
然后有东西进去了。
And I'm like, yeah, it was so funny how.
我想，是的，这真是太有趣了。
I'll never forget Barney saying, my peeps need my tweets.
我永远不会忘记巴尼说，我的窥视者需要我的推文。
My peeps need my tweets.
我的窥视者需要我的推文。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
But it was also, I think it was a way to reward the non-casual viewer.
但我认为这也是奖励非休闲观众的一种方式。
Like the people that would like, that were, you know, the people that would get into fan fiction, like who wanted to find the breadcrumbs and trace them outside of the TV, you know?
就像那些喜欢的人，你知道，那些会进入同人小说的人，就像那些想要找到面包屑并在电视之外追踪它们的人，你知道吗？
And it rewarded long-time viewers, you know.
你知道，它奖励了长期观众。
Like we, there was an episode, Joe, I forget, but it was in, it was at the end of, There's just a slap, one of the slaps.
就像我们一样，有一集，乔，我忘了，但它在里面，在结尾处，只有一巴掌，其中一巴掌。
Oh no, it was the episode when Barney's doing his one man show.
哦不，这是巴尼表演独角戏的那一集。
Yeah.
是的。
And then Marshall just comes up and slaps and I think it was the second slap.
然后马歇尔就过来打了一巴掌，我想这是第二巴掌。
But it was like, that episode had nothing to do with the slap.
但好像，那一集和那一巴掌无关。
It didn't explain the slap that.
并没有解释那一巴掌。
It just was like, here's the second slap for you people who've been tuning in, you know.
就好像，这是给你们这些一直在收听的人的第二记耳光，你知道。
I had, I just like to run through some of the, there were so many funny lines in here that I jotted down.
我有，我只是喜欢浏览其中的一些，这里有很多有趣的台词，我记了下来。
I love Ted and Marshall stealing the blackboard.
我喜欢特德和马歇尔偷黑板。
There's something so funny about the cat burglary of that and the way Ted walks in just, this isn't March Madness, this is March meticulously thought outness, which is a great line.
猫的入室盗窃和泰德走进来的方式非常有趣，这不是疯狂三月，这是三月精心思考的过时，这是一句很棒的台词。
God bless you, Ted, you're reading my blog.
上帝保佑你，特德，你正在阅读我的博客。
It's been a, I've been really bored at work.
这段时间我工作真的很无聊。
I think that's a great, there's a great time.
我认为那真是太棒了，这是一段美好的时光。
I've been really bored at work.
我工作真的很无聊。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
I love who, I think it's Kobe, Robin who guesses, you're going blind and trying to soak up all the beauty in the world before the darkness to say.
我爱谁，我想是科比，罗宾猜想，你会失明并试图在黑暗到来之前吸收世界上所有的美丽。
And that's the correct answer, which is so disturbed.
这就是正确答案，令人如此不安。
Barney really is disturbing himself.
巴尼真的是在困扰自己。
So God damn that made me laugh.
天哪，这让我笑了。
She did the wording of how she guesses that and just spits it out.
她按照她的猜测做了措辞，然后就把它吐了出来。
And then him bumping into the tourists, his eyes in the museum, I didn't even know what he was doing.
然后他撞到了游客，他的眼睛在博物馆里，我什至不知道他在做什么。
Neil's all in, God bless him, he goes all in.
尼尔全力以赴，上帝保佑他，他全力以赴。
Yeah, I loved, why am I not in prison for perjury?
是啊，我爱过，为什么我没有因为作伪证而入狱？
I don't want to talk about work.
我不想谈论工作。
But I don't want to talk about work.
但我不想谈论工作。
I haven't even a Stephen Lloyd line, unless it's a JK, I haven't even...
我什至没有 Stephen Lloyd 的台词，除非是 JK，我什至没有……
Dead in the eyes with an aura of self-loathing and despair, that's all of them.
死气沉沉的眼神中带着一种自我厌恶和绝望的气息，仅此而已。
It really is a very funny episode.
这确实是非常有趣的一集。
There's a lot of winners in here.
这里有很多赢家。
Yeah, I loved it.
是的，我喜欢它。
And Heloise, she helped do the Deku Paj.
还有海洛伊丝，她帮助完成了 Deku Paj。
The Deku Paj?
德库帕杰？
Just gonna learn Deku Paj in there.
只是要在那里学习 Deku Paj。
Yeah.
是的。
And Lily's dancing at the jukebox.
莉莉在自动点唱机上跳舞。
that whole that whole like oceans 11 sequence and Marshall doesn't know how to act normal and what do I usually do with my hands that really made me that was top three laughs for me of the whole episode and the spy music and the seagulls you came back around you're like single needed some good shit yeah shovel some coal on the fire but I love this by music underneath it all with oceans 11 and then Marshall saying not even on the bracket Cinderella story coming out of nowhere.
整个就像《海洋11》的序列，马歇尔不知道如何表现得正常，我通常会用我的手做什么，这真的让我在整集里笑到了前三名，还有间谍音乐和你回来的海鸥，你就像单身需要一些好东西是的，在火上铲一些煤，但我喜欢这一切背后的音乐，《海洋11》，然后马歇尔说，甚至在支架上也没有灰姑娘的故事突然冒出来。
So that was Joe telling us how sports people talk.
这就是乔告诉我们体育界人士如何说话的。
That was Joe being like, get Steven Lloyd and Carter.
乔的意思是，找史蒂文·劳埃德和卡特。
These guys are not going to know like that line.
这些人不会像那句话那样知道。
So thank God for Joe.
所以感谢上帝赐予乔。
And my uncle Willie used to do an all cash sprocket and Staten Island where the winner would get a duffel bag of cash.
我的叔叔威利曾经在史泰登岛举办过一场全现金链轮比赛，获胜者将获得一袋现金。
And so that was from real life.
这就是现实生活中的情况。
It's a duffel bag of cash thing and you get to keep the duffel bag But a hundred thousand dollars was like that felt like pretty significant.
这是一个装现金的行李袋，你可以保留行李袋，但是十万美元感觉非常重要。
Oh, yeah, especially back in the day Tax-free baby.
哦，是的，尤其是在免税宝贝那天。
Well, this is a great opening salvo of an episode is your first sitcom episode ever your first him Yeah, it was written in about two and a half seconds to kill her one.
嗯，这是一集的精彩开场，是你的第一部情景喜剧，是你的第一个他，是的，它是用大约两秒半的时间写的，目的是杀死她。
It's a memorable one we'll probably we will definitely call you back to talk about future ones so thank you thank you for being here we loved talking to you today we loved having you on the show so on both this show and the show show I love watching the every time an episode comes on it's like it's like it's like flipping through a yearbook and you remember the shoe the writers room like everything and so it's always a pleasure so anytime yeah man Joe Ivan I don't think I've seen you since we we left stage 22 it's great to see you and we'll have to find each other out in the world.
这是一个令人难忘的节目，我们可能会打电话给你谈论未来的节目，所以谢谢你，谢谢你今天来到这里，我们喜欢和你聊天，我们喜欢你参加节目，所以在这个节目和节目中，我喜欢看每次一集的播出，就像翻阅年鉴一样，你记得编剧室的鞋子，就像一切一样，所以这总是一种荣幸，所以任何时候，是的，乔·伊万，我想自从我们见面以来我就没有见过你了。我们已经离开了第 22 阶段，很高兴见到你，我们必须在世界上找到彼此。
We'll do something.
我们会做点什么。
Alright buddy.
好吧，伙计。
The great Joe Callie.
伟大的乔·卡利。
We love you buddy.
我们爱你，伙计。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一个点），我们的 Gen Z Masters（我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg）和副制作人 Katherine Grove（凯瑟琳·格罗夫）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，无论在哪里出售书籍，事情都不是这样发生的，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substep.
你也可以在 Substep 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。